Do you know
What it is
To make your dreams come true, Leo?
I've see you working downstairs
You're a good man
This barman, shouldn't have punched the fucking customer
I don't deserve you Leo
I love you so much.
But you don't know me.
I want to know what the deal is with this crazy bartender
You sure you want our help with this?
This kind of this hurts my reputation
Daddy's gotta go.
Oh. No soda.
You're girlfriend has secrets.
You lost mate?
Take a hint and fuck off!
You're not very talkative.
Something's goin' on.
You need to maintain a sense of humour
You gonna give me some -uh-
Trouble big boy?
Or are you gonna channel that famous amish serenity?
Leo
I need to tell you something
This is gonna stop right now
It ain't a secret anymore
Would you do anything for her?
Say you're sorry
Fucking say it!
Why the hell can't he talk?
He doesn't need words